jack flaherty is on the mound for the
cardinals
and he is 9-1 with a 2-6-5 era returned
from the il the kaufman stadium last
friday
gave up a hit in six innings against the
royals
the 1-1 pitch
hit left side on a hop to de young just
past arenado and the out
3-2 pitch
and he struck him out on the inside
corner
the first strikeout for jack flaherty
what's this it's kind of shocking watch
his reaction oh i'm out oh wait
am i out it's a great pitch just the
pitch i'm talking about that down and
then down and away on the corner on two
and one the wind up by flaherty his
pitch yellow shits a bounding ball past
the mound of the second baseman edmund
backhands and throws out yelich it's a
one two three inning for flaherty
against the brewers yeah freddie's been
terrific a 9-3 record 226 his earned run
average and the opponent batting average
for freddie
best in the business at 141 the
strikeout totals 161 are good for
seventh tied for seventh in the national
leagues
and edmond out in front fly ball
shallow right and look at wong just
calmly haul that one in over the
shoulder you could see a little bit of
panic set again with avi garcia
hud wong went a long way in showing some
of that gold glove form right there
here's paul goldschmidt
with aronado on deck
as goldschmidt picks up a base hit
inside the third base line
and he's hustling for two on his way to
second in there with a double one out
double paul goldschmidt sinker running
in hard
great job pulling your hands in so it's
tyler o'neill these are the kind of guys
that you're gonna face these three days
here with milwaukee that you have to put
the home run in your back pocket and you
have to try to make contact up the
middle these aren't the guys you sit
back and try to go deep against 3-0 and
a base hit into left here comes goldie
he will score no throw from yelich in
left and it's one-nothing cardinals they
turned him loose on three-and-oh and
it's one-nothing st louis on an rbi base
hit by tyler o'neal and here is lars
newtbar
2-1 two outs and a two two
into center field off the bat a new par
here comes tyler o'neill two to nothing
cardinals in the crowd at home
chanting new
two-nothing st louis
so two outs in here is goldie
eight for his last 14 with runners in
scoring position since the beginning of
august
trying to add to it a drive into right
garcia back and it's off the wall
goldie on his way to second edmond will
score three to nothing cardinals paul
goldschmidt drives in his 69th this year
three nothing c lewis
the one-two pitch swing and a miss and
strikeout number two
but everything is feeding off that
fastball he is dotting that thing
there's back-to-back strikeouts nine up
nine down jack flaherty looks sharp
connor strickland's going to enter this
game
well
that's the last thing you want to see
so peralta leaves with
something injury or illness
this was the last pitch he saw and yeah
he did a little grimace didn't he
it was a little grimaced there not sure
what it was but
that had to be it
and there's one away now for williams
sends one to right field pretty well hit
back on at noon bar
and he is out of room
a home run for adamus
williams does it again
22nd home run of the season
and the brewers are on the board here in
the fourth inning bobby with a career
best 21 homers this year
got a chance at a career high in rbis
he's got 70 now
garcia in the air to left field back on
it o'neal going back north it's gone
avi garcia
flexing again home run number 22.
so strong such a quick bat let's go
after he makes contact keeping that bad
a little bit more level and able to ride
it out of here the brewers get a little
closer the 2-2
held on to by molina
and a strikeout
number seven tonight for flaherty
there he goes and it's a swing and a
miss on what probably is his final pitch
of the night it's strikeout number eight
for jack flaherty gives the cardinals
six tonight he's going to get the ball
the velocity is not the issue it's the
quickness of the delivery in the arm
there you go ball base hit left side
i just like that match-up lefty yeah you
know velocity a little bit
has to get settled yeah he sometimes
doesn't get ready quick enough and and i
like what you were thinking right there
and then
he does a nice job but you can see
he has to pull his hands in right there
no balls two strikes
and he got him went upstairs and a
strikeout for suitor
never ceases to amaze how
a fastball that's 87 88 miles an hour
continues to fool these hitters up there
and that one broke his bat wong is there
makes the play edmond retired and suiter
does the job
scoring a sixth inning he strands a pair
was not with the club when the brewers
last faced the cardinals
change up on the ground long dives to
his feet and makes the play
telez with a nice stretch
colton wong has put on a defensive
clinic tonight yeah well done able to
get up and make a decent throw to first
and rally tonight has needed every bit
of that height
3-2 pitch
outside and this time oh they do ring
him up again the second time tonight
he's rung up
nolan oronato
the cardinals minus their third baseman
now during the commercial break
nolan arnado ejected by alan porter 3-2
pitch
he got him strikeout
for gallegos
escobar words with the home plate on
fire
and the brewers strand a pair
a scoreless inning for giovanni gallegos
oh man
run him up and it's getting bad now that
wasn't close no it's getting bad now
it's been a terrible strike zone
big zone all night and
now narvaez is giving him an earful and
and it's tough to he's gone
he's got his way
just been a
bad strike zone tonight i mean the
cardinals the brewers both of them
nobody happy about that zone and now
council's gone one away
ninth inning here is garcia
oh garcia
in the air to left field this one's got
a chance this is a
home run
it's up and out of here
abby garcia ties the game
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
wasting no time
now brewer's able to come all the way
back but a first pitch breaking ball
from garcia
traffic moving sosa near the line at
third
no balls and a strike
oh and it gets by and bradley jr is
coming home he will score the brewers
take the lead
molina firing that mask down after that
ball got by him he knew it well you
don't see that every day uris at third
base
and yell it shows bond gets it down it's
a beauty coming in sosa throw to first
not in time
a bunt single and an rbi by yelich
it is 5-3 milwaukee
peterson
drives one to right bobbled out there by
newt barr here comes yellets he's around
third they wave him home throw to the
plate yelich is in there
jace peterson with a base head
six to three milwaukee
up the middle and a base hit
o'neal being waved in
the throw to the plate not in time
scoring tyler o'neill
a base hit by yachty
and the tying run will come to the plate
williams deals fastball got him
he struck him out with the gas
devin williams
saves it for the brewers and they snatch
him back here tonight in saint louis
what a ball game